spec overseas the US envoy negotiating
to end America's longest war is resuming
talks with the Taliban in Qatar this
morning after nearly 18 years of
fighting in Afghanistan it's not just
the Taliban that concerns the US Isis is
also a threat in TS ty ab is at the
peace talks in Doha MT eyes good morning
good morning this is the latest and
possibly last round of talks between the
Taliban and the United States but the
brutal bombing of a wedding in Kabul is
at the top of everyone's minds here
agony in Afghanistan as the death toll
said this weekend's Massacre rises to 80
Isis is claiming responsibility for the
suicide attack casting the longest of
shadows over talks between US
negotiators who are back in Doha for
what they're hoping is a final round of
mediations with the Taliban aimed at
ending America's longest war fourteen
thousand US soldiers remain in
Afghanistan withdrawing them is a key
Taliban demand while Washington wants
guarantees Afghan soil will be used by
militant groups as a staging ground for
global terror attacks like Al Qaeda and
Osama bin Laden did before 9/11 which is
perhaps why president Trump's other
demand leaving US intelligence agents on
the ground in part to monitor Isis
remains the key sticking point speaking
yesterday to Gayle King Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo said defeating the
extremist group remains a top priority
is it gaining strength in your opinion
it's it's complicated that there's
certainly places where Isis is more
powerful today than they were three or
four years ago but the Caliphate has
gone in their capacity to conduct
external attacks has been made much more
difficult even if a deal is agreed this
isn't the end a new phase of
negotiations will begin in Norway this
time between the Taliban and the Afghan
government but these negotiations may
prove even more difficult because these
two warring sides will have to figure
out a way to live with each other in
peace
MTX hey I'm reporting from Doha thank
you